also tonight Joe Biden is weakness
embodied on every single level he's now
mired in scandals and serious
allegations of corruption his policies
now have resulted in nothing but
widespread chaos here at home and abroad
suffering and violence all around the
world and he seems not to know what to
do about any of it and worst of all Joe
does not seem to understand that
literally everything that is going on
domestically and on the world stage
frankly Maybe it's his cognitive decline
maybe it's his cognitive diss but Joe
Biden just is not in touch with reality
today he was seemingly unaware of his
historically bad poll numbers one
questioned by our very own peter Ducey
take a look why do you think it is that
you're trailing Trump and all these
swing state polls because you don't read
the polls I 10 polls eight of them I'm
beating them in those St eight of them
you guys only do two CNN and New York
Times check it out check it out we'll
get your copy of all those are po you
don't believe you're trailing in
Battleground State no I don't now the
New York Times has Biden losing in all
but one Battleground State and by the
way it wasn't a Shan Hannity poll a Fox
News poll the New York Times poll and
meanwhile his approval rating is nearing
alltime lows in nearly every major poll
getting as low as 36 in Reuters and it's
really not a mystery as to why Americans
are far less safe under Joe Biden's
pathetically weak leadership just in the
past 24 hours alone our US soldiers that
are stationed in the Middle East have
been attacked four more times by Iranian
proxies now that brings the total number
of attacks to a whopping 46 in just the
past couple of weeks so how has Joe B
Biden responded sadly he hasn't done
much of anything outside of two very
small strikes on what were remote empty
warehouses in Syria uh that's not a
response Joe seems to think that he's
taking on uh the Iranian revolutionary
guard head on uh no he's not take a look
why did you strike Iran's revolutionary
guard because they struck us and
president bid to hit them again start he
didn't hit the Iranian revolutionary
guard he hit empty warehouses so
needless to say Iran and their Pro
proxies are undeterred now the attacks
have only increased in recent days no
signs of slowing down so naturally
instead of fighting back Joe is ready to
capitulate in fact he is now pressuring
Israel to call for a ceasefire you know
why the ceasefire they are defending
their very country it was the worst
attack in Israel's history one month
after that he's saying oh we need to
pause in the fighting no we don't what
Israel needs is our support for their
complete and total victory over radical
extremist and terrorist Joe seems a
little too uncomfortable politically
with Israel's fight for their survival
against the terrorist regime that is
openly vowing to murder Israelis again
and again and again until they are all
dead take a look did you ask for a 3-day
pause to Netanyahu you know I've been
asking for a pause for a lot more than
three
days
yes did you ask him to pause for 3 Days
to get the hospit for that ask for even
a longer pause for some of it so we have
to ask does your president your
commanderin-chief Joe Biden have any
convictions at all or is he beholden to
the radicals in his party like
congresswoman TB and some others now our
Ally the world's only Jewish state is in
a fight for its very existence at this
moment but the moment Joe gets the
slightest political pressure from inside
his own party and the radicals in his
party he folds like a a house of cards
his fragility is disgusting to witness
and luckily Israel does understand the
mission and that is here's prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu he was on
earlier with Brett be take a look how
firm has the push been by President
Biden his administration for these
humanitarian pauses and what have you
agreed
to well one thing we haven't agreed to
is a ceasefire a ceasefire with Kamas
means surrender to Kamas surrender to
Terror and the victory of the uh Iran's
access of Terror so there won't be a
ceasefire without the release of the
Israeli hostages now it would be a good
time for Joe to stand in solidarity with
our Ally Israel as they stood with us
after
20977 Americans were killed on 911
Israel never wavered in their support of
our actions after that day now would
also be a good time to stand against
anti-Semitism and anti-americanism
here at home and by the way not just
from the shadows of a of a cowardly
press release the explosion of
anti-jewish hatred and extremism across
the country has been downright shocking
I never thought I'd see it in our
lifetime we have seen it on the streets
of major cities we have seen it at
America's quote most prestigious
universities We Have Heard It In the
halls of Congress and the oso virtuous
media mob in fact both fake news CNN and
the Associated Press they actually hired
local freelance journalists to cover the
war in Gaza despite their enthusiastic
participation in the brutal October 7th
massacre in southern Israel they were
reportedly embedded with quote the
terror group Hamas now both the AP and
CNN they have since cut ties with these
so-called photographic journalists or
reporters but only after conservative
Outlets discovered their ties to
terrorism and meanwhile more major
anti-israeli protests this week
including in New York City and some have
demanded that Israel be wiped off the
map as they say this the saying is from
The River To The Sea meaning wipe Israel
off the map others are calling for a
global antifa while we have seen signs
that keep that read quote keep the world
clean featuring a picture Star of David
in a trash can a few protesters holding
glorifying the October 7th attack we
have seen Hamas Flags amid a sea of
Palestinian flags and zero American
flags no one in these protests seems to
blame Hamas for anything instead all the
hatred all the blame is focused in One
Direction Take a Look 5 6 78 5 6 78
Israel is a terror State Israel is the
terrorist State Israel is the terrorist
State Israel is a terrorist State free
free Palestine free free palese free
free free Palestine free free palese hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else